could it be either the most dangerous
region in the world is trying to improve
itself imagine that you're sitting
quietly at a restaurants or cafeteria
and suddenly you begin to hear gunshots
just a few metres away you choose an
empty stomach and opt for a quick escape
wouldn't you now unfortunately these
kind of situations are not uncommon in
many Central American cities cities
where security is noticeable for its
absence in 2018 42 of the 50 most
violent cities in the world were in
Latin America and of these two were in
Honduras one in Guatemala and one in El
Salvador in 2017 alone more than 14,500
homicides were registered in Central
America the vast majority of them more
than 90 percent of them happens in three
countries known as the northern triangle
El Salvador Honduras and Guatemala
[Music]
trilling to say the least so why is
violence so common in this part of the
world what is driving these high crime
rates and Central America always being
in a violent region well let's find out
[Applause]
[Music]
here's question for you have you ever
noticed how curious the map of the
American continent is just look at it
for a second Central America is a bridge
between South America and North America
and this has consequences
the fact that Central America is a
bridge has turned it into the largest
illicit goods highway in the world for
goods produced in South America we're
talking mostly about cocaine no less
than ninety percent of all the cocaine
that enters the United States the
world's largest market for the drug
passes through Central America
[Music]
but don't think this is the only illegal
activity based there not at all
human trafficking trafficking of illegal
immigrants and minors is also booming in
this region and as you can imagine all
of these activities go hand in hand with
organized crime
criminal organizations that control
manage and fight each other for
dominance of all of these businesses
we're talking about a huge industry and
a highly structured one with managers
administrators lawyers corporate
advisors diversification investment
strategies and a whole lot else an
industry that is increasingly becoming
involved in developing a presence in
Central America check it out
Mexican cartels are moving 90 percent of
their activities to Central America
according to research the increasing
pressure from the state in Mexico in
recent years has made this type of mafia
want to settle in countries with weaker
and less vigilant governments and you
know what the truth is that these groups
these macro crime companies have managed
to take over much of Central America
Mexico crime exporter to Central America
Mexico or rather the Mexican cartels are
slowly becoming the leaders the biggest
drug business owners in Latin America of
course they've been competing with
Colombian groups for quite some time the
Mexican cartels already control the
majority of the main routes for
transporting illegal goods and that
pretty much means controlling all of
Central America
now let's put ourselves in the shoes of
these great bosses for a second imagine
that you're one of them what's the
fastest way to control the Central
American territory how can you settle in
and dominate this region exactly a good
option would be to establish alliances
with the native criminal groups those
that were there before you groups that
have the necessary infrastructure
contacts and knowledge of the territory
that you need we're talking about groups
that are single velocity work with
whoever gives you the most cash this is
hardly surprising we all know the power
of the dollar but how and why did
Central America becomes so ripe for
exploitation by the Mexican drug
traffickers to understand that we need
to go back to the 1990s you see the key
moments when the players changed
happened between 1991 and 1993 when the
modeun cartel suffered its greatest
defeat Pablo Escobar's fall as well as
that of the cartels main bosses also
meant losing the huge influence and
power that they had in Central America
which their gains thanks to their
alliances with local groups who worked
directly for them and that was the
Mexican group's great window of
opportunity which of course they took
advantage of by storming into Central
America with the objective of completely
controlling that important bridge which
connects the production centers with the
consumption center
but surely some of you might be thinking
now well Simon there are several
different cartels in Mexico didn't that
pose a problem and well yes indeed it
did after the Mexicans arrived Central
America became the kinds of battlefields
between the different Mexican cartels
who fought to control the transport
routes and that's precisely one of the
reasons that violence in Central America
increased dramatically
until finally each cartel claimed their
own territory you could say that Mexican
cartels became major exporters of
violence and crime to their southern
neighbors check out the case of Honduras
for example you see the power struggles
between Mexican cartels and local groups
to increase their influence and gain
control of the business explain much of
the increased crime during those years
now let's put all big numbers aside
let's focus on the streets how exactly
to all these battles between cartels and
Central American criminal groups affects
the safety of regular citizens while
listen up when violence doesn't find an
enemy we've already showed you that the
Central American north triangle has the
highest crime rates in the world that's
why we ask an essential question is
there a solution what does the region
need to achieve social peace
[Music]
while the truth is but this goal seems
very very complicated why well check
this out
Honduran president's brother is found
guilty of drug trafficking Honduran
president is accused of drug conspiracy
prosecutors say drug proceeds were
allegedly used to support Honduran
president Juan Orlando Hernandez's 2013
election son of X Honduran president
gets 24 years for u.s. drug charge
former El Salvador president Sokka gets
two year prison term for bribery against
such a backdrop of corruption
institutionalized drug trafficking and
other despicable actions who would put
up their hands to fight crime especially
if crime itself isn't charged if the
highest spheres in power in Central
America have such close ties very close
with the great criminals how on earth is
anyone going to fight them and it's not
just that they can't they just don't
want to it's a matter of incentives no
one absolutely no one wants to kill the
goose that lays the golden eggs
however himself because despite this
harsh reality the truth is that in
recent years Central America has
experienced a gradual reduction in
homicide rates this has led many
politicians to stand up of course in
many cases it wasn't thanks to the
government's but rather in spite of it
let's take a look at El Salvador
[Music]
in El Salvador in 2018 they had 15%
fewer homicides than in the previous
year but even so it was still a very
high number three thousand three hundred
and forty homicides in one year in a
country of less than six and a half
million inhabitants
El Salvador is the country with the
highest homicide rate in the most
dangerous region of the planet so we
could say it's the most dangerous
country in the world but even though the
country has encouraged it the truth is
that this history of violence comes from
way back long before the Mexican cartels
ever set foot in Central America
[Music]
we've talked about them for a while on
visual politic the maras are a dangerous
criminal gang member group based in Los
Angeles that are dedicated mainly to
drug and weapons trafficking money
laundering immigrant trafficking and
prostitution
[Music]
since the 1960s they've been one of El
Salvador's greatest security challenges
the Mara Salvatrucha or ms-13 and
barrier 18 are the two main branches
which has expected often fight each
other and have been trying to control
the Salvadoran territory for many years
in order to better carry out their
illegal activities
it's been this fight over the territory
that has spread pain and suffering all
over El Salvador
[Music]
and of course these Maris are still
fully active so why is it the crime has
decreased in recent years well take a
look at this drug traffickers use mods
and street gangs to dominate Central
America yeah as you can see
paradoxically this alliance could
explain much of the reduction in
homicides why well the answers complex
but simplifying a bit we could say that
currently the Mara's are acting as
branches of the most powerful Mexican
cartels such as the Sinaloa cartel or
Los Zetas
interestingly this alliance could be
causing parts of these gangs forces to
be operating in wider fields protecting
the Mexican cartels activities and thus
moving them away from the streets let's
just say there are bigger businesses
than extorting money from the corner
store and that's not the only change in
addition Mexican cartels have noticed
that Mara's are tremendously effective
in controlling cities and infusing the
greatest possible terror so they are
recruiting troops and moving to Mexico
to support their activities and to train
their own people basically they're
enlisting them that way Mexicans have
introduced the Mara's into the
large-scale international drug
trafficking business but how exactly all
the gangs helping the Mexican cartels
well obviously not for the common good
[Music]
they are teaching them the most horrible
cruel and ruthless ways of treating
their adversaries these are techniques
they are moving to and implementing in
Mexico itself
[Music]
I think that now you can understand
better why crime has decreased in recent
years and yes unfortunately it has
little to do with governments or with
the us's plan for Central America and
more to do with the dynamics of the
crime industry surely at this point many
of you might be thinking that well this
is just getting a bit out of hands right
marah's and cartels collaborating
governments bought by and backing
criminal interests ineffective and
corrupt security forces bribed courts
against such a backdrop do you think
that our Salvadoran Central America in
general have any chance to escape this
vicious cycle what can Salvadorians do
to stop being the most dangerous country
in the world well I'm sorry to say that
it doesn't look like an easy task
but who knows scratch the arrival of
this man who's very well known for
leading as governments through tweets
can make step forward by showing that
one of the problems of Central America
and perhaps the most important one is
that there's a lack of political will
[Music]
Nighy buchelli
an outsider candidate claims victory in
El Salvador election Michaela came to
power in early 2019 with the key promise
of making El Salvador a safer and less
corrupt country will he achieve it well
only time will tell but for now it looks
like he's taking decisive steps to do so
of course with Latin American
politicians well no one ever knows in
this region the forecasts especially if
they're optimistic usually aren't worth
very much
el salvador launches anti-corruption
commission inspired by guatemala and be
careful because corruption isn't a minor
problem in this region fighting
corruption is necessary step to break
the link between power and crime while
having reached this point we've seen why
politicians can't take the credit
even if homicide rates are decreasing
we've seen that nowadays there's little
room for hope in Honduras and that el
salvador could be facing a great
opportunity for real change
however in this delicate balance of
grime and power we need to include
another Central American country a
country that isn't a part of the
northern triangle but which has recently
seen a dramatic increase in violence in
many cases are very different violence
because drug trafficking isn't the only
disease that plagues Central America so
listen up Nicaragua the end of a dream
[Music]
we talked about this in several videos
in Nicaragua there's a phenomenon that
doesn't happen in many other Latin
American countries that is the use of
violence as a form of political control
[Music]
it's a scenario similar to the one found
in Venezuela ins which has suddenly
ended the myth that Nicaragua was the
exception the only safe country in the
most dangerous region of the world for
example in 2017 Nicaragua had only seven
homicides per hundred thousand
inhabitants while at the same time in
Honduras it was 40 51 in El Salvador and
28 in Guatemala the difference is
remarkable but that doesn't really mean
Nicaragua is a safe place to live time
has certainly shown us that
[Music]
the sandanista National Liberation Front
ruling party has completely penetrated
the state's power agencies politicizing
them by getting like-minded people into
key positions and using true
paramilitary groups to repress the
population
[Music]
Nicaraguan sirens Daniel Ortega has
literally begun employing thugs to do
the dirtiest work in the name of the
police and to the Army during the
protests
[Music]
and yes from a political and
institutional point of view this is one
of the worst decisions a leader can make
alarm raises over wave of crimes with
viciousness that bear the seal of
paramilitaries of Daniel Ortega in
Nicaragua in 2018 violence rates
skyrocketed throughout the brutal
repression of civil protesters by
President Daniel Ortega regime because
as soon as a government begins using
irregular forces to repress the masses
they create conditions that legalize and
normalize violence and give impunity at
a general level you could say the
floodgates of crime are opened with the
first blow we've seen it's in Venezuela
and we're starting to see it in
Nicaragua anyway as you can see crime
corruption and a lack of safety are the
great evils that are hanging over
Central America in many cases if not in
all cases this is happening with the
approval and complicity of the political
powers
[Music]
we wanted to make this video to better
show you exactly what is happening in
this region of the world the most
dangerous region on the planet in terms
of violence we also wanted to show you
what is hiding behind the decreasing
number of homicides that have been seen
in recent years but now it's your turn
do you think that safety in Central
America is an impossible dream can the
nation really get rid of the curse of
drug trafficking and organized crime
well please leave your answers in the
comment section below and I really hope
you enjoyed this video please do hit
that like button if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
also please do check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always I'll see you next
video
[Music]